ah seriously I'm not talking to you I'm
mad at you oh no really
a flower okay
wolf everybody someone teaches to walk
around in circles you know support lays
down is my favorite thing to teach
you're probably asking yourself how a
stork a girl and a baby wound up in this
situation let me go back and start at
the beginning of the story Dona you know
I built my office entirely out of glass
even though birds can't see glass I do
not Monday it'll all be yours sorry any
monumental screw-up orphaned tulip
Junior a two of us just buy an orphan
hers merit that's a quail and EMU
there's a chicken that cannot fly she's
helping us achieve our dreams
what what is that
storks don't deliver babies anymore if
this baby finds our family then maybe I
can find Lyon you'll find your family
you think for sure this is crazy we are
delivering a baby if anyone finds out
about this I am dead meat powder I don't
know what you're talking about I saw two
that fit that description the other day
no man I will not be a friend sorry
thought we were vibing destroy the whole
room we have to replace the chimney with
a slide for when the storks deliver my
baby brother what he said to me
but down that baby are you in love I am
in luck
are you in love I'm in love too angry I
agree I agree I agree woman infant
production facility we have perfected
and streamlines the process devising a
zero mistake workflow red mark using the
most cutting-edge technology